today house democrats and that includes
adam kinzinger voted to criminalize
their political opposition essentially
under the guise of preventing domestic
terrorism now piggybacking on the
horrific buffalo mass shooting tragedy
the bill is going to set up duplicative
offices to investigate domestic
terrorism at the dhs and also the doj so
what's the goal here
more surveillance and tracking of
americans this is all political and the
bill now moves to the senate our next
guest issued his own warning about this
on twitter today not only did every
single house democrat vote for biden's
40 billion war package every one of them
also just voted to give the fbi dhs and
doj more power to fight domestic
terrorism it barely passed because most
gop voted against it the squad comes
through again for the u.s security state
glenn greenwald welcome um glenn now one
of the bill's main supporters
congressman brad schneider claims that
the legislation was adjusted to specif
specify that none of its tenants would
undermine first amendment rights
and it previously passed in a voice vote
i guess in 2020 so what could be
problematic about this glenn he tells us
it's not going to really hurt first
amendment concerns
pretty much every bill that has been
enacted since the
9 11 attack or
the first war on terror contained
similar promises and as almost everybody
agrees in many many instances many of
those bills ran roughshod over the civil
liberties not of foreign nationals but
of american citizens it went way too far
most people agree in retrospect this is
so much more dangerous laura because
unlike the first war on terror which it
was for all its flaws at least directed
outward this one is increasingly a war
on terror on domestic soil aimed not at
foreign nationals but american citizens
and i've been on your show many times
going back to even before biden's
inauguration
warning that this is the democrats plan
because even before january 6 biden came
out and said a new war on terror against
domestic extremism is my number one
legislative priority and they exploited
january 6 and now they're exploiting
these buffalo shootings to give all of
these agencies
more power to surveil and monitor and
control our dissent and free speech
there are no standards here so these
assurances that free expression and
political participation
they're sacrosanct they won't be touched
here
there's no checks and balances whatever
they consider to be hate speech at the
moment maybe if it's you post something
against lockdowns that's hate speech
maybe if you criticize i don't know some
new spending bill that's hate speech
because certain people are going to get
that money so there's no end in sight as
to what constitutes hate speech and then
could lead to domestic terror down the
road
yeah you know this is the problem with a
very similar attempt the controversy
that
just erupted where the department of
homeland security announced they were
creating a board to combat quote unquote
disinformation in theory
nobody's against disinformation and
there too they promised they said oh
this board is actually going to protect
your civil liberties so you don't need
to worry but the democrats think every
piece of reporting or every view that
subverts their agenda or contravenes
their view is disinformation remember
prior to the election they called the
hundred biden laptop that we all know
now is authentic russian disinformation
and got it censored from the internet
and so when you put these extremely
elastic phrases
as the centerpiece for the government's
power they can control hate speech they
can control disinformation that's
exactly when constitutional mischief and
civil liberties violations start to
occur in everything they're doing aura
is about fortifying their power to
monitor and control domestic political
activity
glenn on the issue of ukraine i know
you've been monitoring the spending
bills uh in the senate a
mitch mcconnell was on fox tonight
discussing this let's watch
whether it will cost
more or not remains to be seen but i
think the important thing to remember is
what would have been the cost of not
acting it would have been way more
way more than 40 billion
i'm not sure where we get that calculus
um but nevertheless 40 billion dollars
and kamala harris
today is not ruling out that we're
spending a lot more i mean this could go
into the hundreds of billions could it
not
no it is going to go into 100 billion
hundreds of billions that 40 billion
figure that mitch mcconnell cited is
false they just voted to add 40 billion
dollars more on top of the 14 billion
they've already spent which is 54
billion dollars just 10 weeks into a war
laura that they all say is going to last
not months but years we just got done
spending two trillion dollars for a
20-year war in afghanistan
that achieved nothing other than the
death of any of our soldiers the
destruction of that country only for the
taliban to waltz right back in to the to
powers that we were never there in the
first place what you're talking about is
not sending billions of dollars to help
the ukrainian people this money is going
to raytheon lockheed martin the cia the
standard weapons manufacturers and
security state to do what nobody knows
rand paul wanted to just slow down the
bill to provide some oversight and they
didn't want that so you have huge
amounts of money flying out the door
that will easily reach hundreds of
billions of dollars way more than the
russians spend on their entire military
for the year and nobody can articulate a
strategy for what we're doing let alone
any benefits for the american people
there yeah there's no accountability
like we lost what is it 80 billion
dollars worth of equipment we left
behind in afghanistan lord knows where
this stuff is going to end up and and
tonight um mcconnell really went after
rand paul and you know it's always the
isolationist wing but they'll never
debate like i want to see rand paul and
mcconnell they're both really smart
people i want to see them debate
the numbers and the issue to town halls
all across kentucky and see which person
comes out on top in that debate who do
you think will come out on top glenn
with the public
well i mean i think rand paul has the
much better argument because no matter
what you think about the ukraine about
ukraine and we all feel sympathy for the
ukrainians this is by far by far the
most dangerous war the united states has
fought in decades because our opponent
is not iraq or afghanistan but a country
with the largest nuclear stockpile on
the planet so we're risking nuclear
annihilation and for what that's the
question that they can't answer no i
want to see the debate not just the vote
for the money but the debate glenn thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else